so i'm not getting any younger in fact
i'm actually 34 this week i think and
whilst that's not ancient it certainly
is getting to the point where i noticed
that i take a little bit longer to
recover from training where i'm slightly
more prone to picking up injuries and
this is also compounded by the fact that
i'm a parent soon to be a parent of two
so yeah i need to start thinking ahead
if i want to carry on doing this into
old age if i want to carry on training
like i did when i was 18 which i do more
or less then i need to plan ahead i need
to train smart and i need to make sure
that i'm strengthening those weaker
areas that are more prone to injury thus
i came up with this specific routine
that i call fortify a selection of
exercises that i can use either
altogether in one workout or i can tack
onto the end of other workouts or that i
can spread throughout the day i call
this kind of programming modular you can
kind of tack on these different things
that you want that provide different
benefits and in this case it's all about
bulletproofing these are the exercises
that i have selected from my own
personal needs and goals and for my own
weak areas can pick and choose which
ones work for you and apply them as you
see fit without further ado this is my
fortify workout here are the exercises
by the way if you like any of these
clothes then you can get them in the
little carousel thing underneath this
video
so first up we're talking these and
we're talking the hindu squats the hindu
squat is very similar to a regular squat
except you're on the balls of your feet
and you're bending with your knees going
past your toes so if you guys have
watched any knees over toes guys or just
youtube in general then you know that
these days the advice is no longer to
avoid knees going past toes like the
plague in fact we generally consider
this to be a great way to strengthen the
knees it's not rocket science if you
have a weak area that's prone to injury
then completely avoiding training it is
not the solution so one of the most
popular ways to train these over toes is
with the [ __ ] squat where lean all the
way backwards and move your knees past
your toes squatting like that this is a
fantastic workout for the quads as well
however it's also a bit more advanced
it's something a lot of people can't
actually do and of course the other
issue of this movement is that it's it's
taxing and the whole point of this
workout is that we're just trying to
strengthen ourselves we're adding it on
top of our main workouts we don't want
to be taxing ourselves here that's not
the point so the hindu squat is a much
gentler and nicer way to get into that
position where you're squatting with
your knees past your toes that isn't
going to cause too much damage or stress
the best part is as well it can be
easily adapted so you just go down as
low as you want to if you're
experiencing any knee pain just move in
the range that doesn't cause pain and
you'll gradually strengthen it to the
point where you can start to squat all
the way down like this
now actually if you're doing it the
official proper way like a real hindu
squat there's also some arm movement
involved and there's a specific
breathing pattern where you're actually
breathing through the nose and you
inhale on the way down and exhale on the
way up which is all quite unusual this
breath work actually brings all sorts of
additional benefits because it trains
debris through the nose which is
fantastic for all sorts of reasons
however we're focusing right now on
strengthening your knees you don't need
to worry about that unless you're
interested one of the simplest ways to
think about mobility and resilience as
you get older is the simple rule of use
it or lose it i know that the day i stop
bounding up the stairs is the day that
i'm going to stop being able to bound up
the stairs which is why i always try and
move as much as i can throughout the day
this is a kind of position just being
able to squat down on the balls of your
toes that everybody should be able to
perform if you want to make sure that
you can still squat down and play with
your grandkids when you're older then
using the [ __ ] squat is a great way to
ensure that that happens
next one i'm going to demonstrate is the
gamma cast
you've seen me do this a few times on
the channel
basically it's a fantastic way to train
and strengthen and bulletproof the
shoulders for this one i'm going to be
using a heavy club a club bell but you
can also use other implements as i'll
demonstrate in a moment basically what
you're going to do is take your weight
hold it in front of you like this and
then dive it around your head and back
to the other side trying to keep your
torso nice and straight as you do
there's a variation of this where you
come to one and eleven o'clock like so
because holding it in that position is a
bit more of a challenge for the grip
so you're getting that extra bang for
your buck but you don't need to do that
if your focus
at the moment is primarily
on bulletproofing as you can see we're
going all the way around the head
and at the same time when you're back in
this position
there's a little bit of a weighted
stretch going on which is working on
mobility it's also applying traction to
the joint gently pulling it apart
instead of always compressing like
you're doing when you do something like
a military press
and all this makes it fantastic for the
entire
your shoulder region if you want to
build stability and thereby prevent
injury it's also just a great
exercise and of course you have the
added benefit
of core stability on the
rotational plane as you try and prevent
your body from twisting and bending
the great gamma reportedly did thousands
of these per day
which doing high repetitions of anything
is going to ensure you get a massive
blood supply to that region really
strengthening the tissue around there
particularly tendons which don't get as
much blood as muscle does
okay so the next one i want to show you
is one i got from the squat university
instagram account i believe that they
got it from somewhere else so this is
the
ballistic kettlebell row and it's
probably easier to just show you it
first and then explain afterwards
so you're gonna be in a bent down
position like this with your back
straight chest up hold the kettlebell in
one hand then you're going to roll it up
and swap and catch
hashtag pray for my decking
so what's going on here well just like
any kind of bench row you've got an
isometric contraction in the erector
spinae so you're nicely strengthening
the back to avoid injury but this
movement goes one step further because
you're launching the weight in the air
and then catching it again and what this
does is it forces you to brace in
anticipation of catching the weight so
i've talked in the past about the
multifidus this is the muscle or group
of muscles that runs up either side of
the spine and helps to stabilize it it
provides a spinal stiffness particularly
when it comes to bending and rotating
and its job is to not only strengthen
and keep the spine straight and strong
but also to anticipate movement so when
you step off a step and you think you're
on the bottom step but actually there's
one more step or vice versa and you have
that real sudden judder it's because
your body's prepared for one thing but
the reality is different so this is how
we need to think about strength it's not
just about having the strength it's
about applying the strength correctly
for the environment and that involves
all the different senses your visual
motor landscape so you need to see
what's about to happen and embrace in
anticipation of that happening and if
you think of performing a clean or power
clean or something like that or snatch
you're about to exert this massive
amount of force and just before you do
it your body needs to brace in all the
right places to make you strong and
prevent injury so this is a very light
way to practice that you're feeling the
weight moving you're seeing the weight
moving and you're bracing your core and
your spine in just the right way to
counteract those forces this is a
fantastic way to prevent a lower back
injury
[Music]
so another one for the lower back in
particular is the good morning so the
good morning is probably well known as
the exercise that actually broke bruce
lee's back which is not what we want but
we're going to be using it in a very
mild way here that doesn't involve
weight even so the good morning simply
involves bending forward except it's not
really a bend it's a hinge
so if you're doing it with your body
weight feet apart hands behind your head
or on the side of your head and then
you're just going to hinge forwards
to bend
and obviously you can go a little bit
further
keeping your back straight all the time
of course
when you perform a good morning you
should feel a nice stretch in your
hamstrings which is a great way to
prevent injury particularly because so
many of us have short hamstrings and
this is famous for causing injuries in
football players and other kinds of
athletes at the same time also teaches
us the correct hip hinge movement and it
adds just a little bit of extra
resistance for the erector spinae just
to strengthen those slightly through a
range of motion the good morning can be
performed with a whole bunch of weight
on your back in fact some power lifters
do this as a way to strengthen their
core and their spine for big lifts such
as the squat or the deadlift however
that's not how i'm going to be using it
here that said if you do want to add a
just an empty bar for instance and this
is a great way to add just a little bit
of extra resistance to make the move
slightly more challenging if you do that
i recommend using a lower bar position
because obviously when you're leaning
forwards you don't want the weight to be
rolling towards your neck at the same
time of course the bar needs to stay
over the top of the center of your feet
the entire way through you don't want it
in front of you because then you're at a
very bad angle and if you don't face
plant then you might find that your back
gives out so
this is just quite a technical lift if
you're going to add weight then make
sure you know what you're doing if
you're not adding weights then you can
still imagine that bar being over the
center of your toes in order to make
sure you're using the correct form
this is another one i learned from
watching knees over toes guy ben patrick
i'm just going to level with you he's
got so much fantastic information i
could just give you a whole bunch of his
exercises and they'd all be fantastic
for bulletproofing and improving
performance as well this one was
particularly useful for me however and
that's why i integrated it into my own
training that's the tibialis anterior
raise so basically what you're going to
be doing is raising your toes upwards
using the tibialis anterior and the
tibialis anterior is the muscle on your
shin on the front and it's responsible
for dorsiflexion lifting your foot
upwards now you might think this is a
kind of pointless muscle because i mean
you're always pushing through the ground
with your foot when you're running or
jumping but how often do you need to
lift your foot upwards with any kind of
force well one obvious example of how
you might train this naturally if we
were in a more varied environment is
through swimming however it's also
important because we use it to absorb a
lot of impact when we land from a jump
this is the kind of first line of
defense when you're landing from a jump
when your legs are impacting on the
ground as you're running and this is one
of the things that causes shin splints
[Music]
so to do this movement all you're going
to do i'm leaning against the wall here
is lean against the wall
and then you're just going to raise your
toes upwards
as high as you can
then you can lean the angle back
slightly
and the great thing about this
is that your legs are going to be in the
position that they would be if you are
decelerating or often landing from a
jump
where your shins are coming down at an
angle
and another trick you can actually use
is just to walk on your heels with your
toes constantly pointing upwards it
doesn't take long for this to create a
surprising burn in the front of the legs
there another thing you can do to try
and increase the difficulty slightly is
to use a wedge and to put your heels
slightly higher than your toes and this
allows you to travel further and
increases the difficulty i also
recommend you flip this round and do it
the other way so that you're performing
a calf stretch and then a calf raise
next up is one of my favorite exercises
which i've talked about a lot on this
channel before i did a whole video on
them and that's the inverted push-up
also known as the bodyweight row various
other names basically what you're doing
here is you're hanging underneath the
bar or parallel bars with your hands
you're extending fully and then you're
pulling yourself up so that your sternum
reaches the bar or comes close to where
your hands are located and what you're
doing here is not only obviously
training the lats and the shoulder to a
lesser extent but you're also
maintaining a rigid position with your
core once again and specifically this is
an anti-flexion movement what that means
is that your body wants to bend this way
because your heels are on the floor your
butt wants to sink towards the ground
which means you need to extend which is
anti-flexion so you're once again
bracing the erector spinae your whole
back nice and straight and just
maintaining this kind of rigidity this
is really important because we train the
opposite so often when we're doing
push-ups if you do plank and you're
training it specifically and we're
always in a hunched over forwards
position when we're sitting at a desk so
in other words this is what you need to
balance yourself out and if you do a lot
of push-ups it's a really good idea to
also do lots of bodyweight rows an added
bonus if you also make sure that you're
fully retracting the shoulder blades
when you're at the top of the movement
then this is also going to train your
straight arm strength and your scapular
control and this is really useful when
it comes to things like rose because it
allows you to support the shoulder more
so and avoid shoulder injury as well
another move from another culture that
you might not have used in the past is
the sumo squat with shikoh not like
chico time this is the leg lift that you
sometimes see sumo wrestlers do where
they raise up one side and then slam the
leg down the sumo squat is really good
because it activates the hip adductors
it creates a nice stretch and it trains
your legs and your hips in the frontal
plane we still often move forwards and
backwards never side to side and this
can lead to injury whether you're
running on an uneven surface or you're
suddenly changing direction if you don't
have that strength there this can lead
to issues and it helps to keep the knee
tracking nicely where it's supposed to
be stacking the joints then by adding in
that leg raise as well you're raising
your leg up and so you're strengthening
it in both directions you're also
building stability and balance on one
leg which of course is really useful
whatever kind of sport you're engaging
in so i highly recommend trying this out
and now there is a proper way to perform
chico i'd probably completely butcher it
but you don't necessarily have to use
the exact same technique the idea is
that you're squatting down nice and low
and then you're raising yourself up and
raising that leg out to the side before
moving back onto the other side shift
your leg onto the supporting side as for
the sumo squat itself you just want to
take your feet slightly wider than
shoulder width apart slightly wider than
you normally would turn your toes out
slightly about 45 degrees and then turn
the knees out as well make sure that
they're following the feet you don't
want them turning inwards that kind of
defeats the point and that can cause
pain in and of itself and obviously this
builds that sweet hip mobility as well
next one i've been using this is one
that's particularly useful for me
personally may not apply to you is the
camel pose and here what you're doing is
you're getting onto your knees and then
you're trying to extend the back
focusing on the thoracic spine you do
this by pushing the sternum up towards
the sky and opening up the chest and
this will help to improve not only
mobility in your spine but also
proprioception so that you can actually
feel and control the spine you can also
do edo portals favorite the spinal wave
if you want to do this properly you need
to sit up on your knees and then reach
all the way back and proper yogis can
grab their ankles and do all sorts of
cool stuff i'm nowhere near that but i
basically just want to be able to
control my back so that i bend more of
the thoracic spine and less at the
lumbar spine because that's another way
that mobility can really enhance
longevity and prevent injury because
we'd much rather that thoracic spine was
bending rather than the lumbar spine and
if you don't have that mobility then
it's going to have to go somewhere else
basically if you look at a back bridge
the best ones bend all the way around
and particularly at the middle of the
spine not so much down the bottom if
you're just bending at the bottom it
probably means that you don't have
enough spine mobility also probably not
enough shoulder mobility so you want to
work on both those things someone like
dr stuart mcgill would tell you not to
extend the spine in this way because it
causes too much compression personally i
want to be able to do things like
hamstrings so it's not an issue i do
believe that you can do this safely and
into old age however like i said your
mileage may vary it depends on what you
want from your training if you're just
doing big heavy lifts you don't
necessarily need or want this kind of
mobility
[Music]
as for the shoulders one of the best
things you can do to improve mobility
there and thereby prevent that kind of
cascading effect is hangs which also
builds a lot of grip strength stretches
out the lats and at the same time they
create traction on the spine moving it
nicely apart and just helping it to feel
healthy and loose they do say after all
that you are as old as your spine tang's
also fantastic because they're an
isometric hold and isometrics are a
brilliant way to train anything when it
comes to recovery because you're not
moving through a range of motion thereby
you're minimizing the risk of injury but
you're also sending the blood to that
area and just like high flush sets this
can also work as a form of occlusion
basically trapping the blood in the
muscle building up metabolites and
really accelerating that recovery
if you want to perform the hand
correctly with the focus being on
shoulder mobility and stretching out the
lats then you want to perform it
passively what that means is that you
want to only contract intense muscles
that need to be contracted and tense so
you want to relax the rest of the body
and particularly the lats you might
think you're hanging completely without
inserting any strength but then you'll
notice that you can actually relax more
and shrink down into it further bringing
your shoulders up more and feeling that
stretch in your lats and that's what we
want if the focus is mobility which for
me it is
so this next one i like because we can
do it sitting down i'm talking about
wrist curls both supinated wrist curls
and pronated wrist curls and these are
important not only to strengthen the
wrists but also to prevent injury in the
elbows and that's because a lot of the
tendons in the forearm they span both
the wrist joint and the elbow joint for
example you have the carpi radialis
brevis and this goes from the third
metacarpal through to the lateral
epicondyle at the end of the humerus and
so by strengthening the wrist you can
prevent things like tennis elbow or
lateral epicondylitis
so you want to use a weight that's light
enough that you can wrist curl support
your forearm on something and then
you're moving literally just the wrist
and the important thing here is
obviously balance because we do so much
wrist flexion that we also need wrist
extension otherwise we're going to
become lopsided and this is what leads
to injuries now my video talking about
adapting to your environment i said how
it could actually be a reductionist
approach try and chase down every single
last muscle group that gets overlooked
and to try and create balance that way
this is certainly true the best way to
create balance in your grip is just to
use your arms and hands in a lot of
different ways the best way to create
hip stability and knee stability is to
walk a lot on uneven terrain the best
way to balance out dorsiflexion and
plantar flexion is to do some swimming
as well let the environment shape you
because it has more variables to create
a more well-rounded physique however
this isn't always possible especially if
you don't have space to go running
through the woods and so this is where
looking at particular weak areas that go
wrong and making sure to add in some
functional training there can be really
useful and this is why i take issue with
people who talk about you know strength
being strength as long as you're doing
your big three lifts you don't need
anything else because it doesn't work
like that you don't build strong squats
and then suddenly you have perfect
balance in your forearms and this kind
of focus on just one type of strength is
what leads to imbalances and then later
pain and that's why i think it's really
important to make sure you're training
in balance and not just focusing on one
particular skill follow the link in the
description down below it will take you
to the bioneer blog where you'll find
not only a full routine using these
exercises with sets and reps and things
but also a few additional exercises that
i also use as part of my fortify workout
that's the point here as well these are
exercises that benefit me that i do on a
regular basis because they train the
things that i'm looking for they fix
weak areas and they support the kind of
movements i want you might not
necessarily benefit from these same
exercises and that's why we need to look
around and we need to find different
things and adapt them to our own use we
need to absorb what is useful reject
what is not and add what is uniquely our
own
i just came up with that no idea you
know just popped into my head anyways i
hope that you can find some exercises in
this routine that are useful and add
them to your own training and get some
benefits as a result thank you so much
for watching this one guys if you found
it useful interesting then please leave
a like and share around that helps me
out immensely if you like this kind of
training that looks at functional
performance and trying to build balance
and longevity then you'll enjoy my ebook
and training program super functional
training there's a discount on right now
and there's a link in the description
down below where you can check it out i
also have a print book called functional
training and beyond which is an
introduction to the concept of
functional training as it applies to
athletes and the average joe either way
thank you so much for watching and i'll
see you next time
bye for now